before we talk music I want to talk this
album cover all right tell me you're
lying on an actual bed of like a
gajillion diamonds what's happening
there I I so am
I am from it's from the diamonds and
dance floors a visualizer for dancing's
done and so when I finished that
visualizer I was like okay I've been
sitting on the other album cover for way
too long it's time to swap it and if
we're swapping it for this and it really
looked like the cover to me even though
I love the other cover as well now we
have multiple covers I love it so for
someone who loves their sweatpants life
so much like
how comfortable was it scale of one to
ten to be lying down on that
it was not comfortable I was uh I had a
little tear go down I was like ow they
were poking my booty and my back and my
arms and my head and they were just like
poking my entire back it was horrible
you suffered for your art you got to
suffer for the art
that's it so you know you saw that
visual you loved it I imagine you know
your music videos you see them amazing
you listen to the way the music works
out amazing how often in your career
career right now are you seeing products
that you work on and you were just going
this is exceeding what I dreamed for
myself
everything every day I freak out I'm
just like I look in the mirror and I'm
just like really you're living your
dream this is this is crazy to me I I
wanted this since I was so little and
I'm actually living my dream I'm
traveling the world I'm meeting fans I'm
performing now all over the world this
year I'm starting a headline tour this
this year I can't wait
how amazing is to be able to say that
out loud and when and when were you able
to say like with confidence I am doing
this headlining tour this is me
I I can say that now I'm excited you
know last year was a big learning year
for me I had to learn who I was like I
was kind of stagnant after releasing the
first single off the first album I got
kind of thrown off by a breakup and I I
went through a really hard time last
year um but I am back and I have never
felt more like myself
um I'm excited
when you're writing songs and releasing
music that is about experiences like
that let's say past relationships
is it primarily for you to get that
stuff out there for yourself emotionally
or do you want people to listen and also
kind of like take in the lessons that
you've had to learn as well
for sure I hope they don't make the same
mistakes I did
um but I am a hopeless romantic so I
mean I just hope I don't get heartbroken
again that really hurt it's stung and I
never felt like that before I think for
everyone dealing with anything this
album is meant to be empowering to get
you out of the dark place that you feel
like you're in it's meant to make you
want to go dance with your with your
friends and and forget all of your
worries
if you could live in any era of like
dance music that you're not in now any
past era go out party with people which
one would you want it to be this is hard
this is really hard can I say the 80s
should I say the 80s
80 sounds fun
so what was the like what were the
artists that inspired this album there's
I hear a lot of popular but I hear like
90s house
um Disco who was inspiring this for you
there's definitely a lot of 90s house
there's disco pop disco there's there's
um like a lot of like Michael Jackson
production Vibe like you hear a
sleepwalker Million Dollar Baby like
that like old school Vibe I think pop is
the
throughout lines or at all but I think I
wanted each song to have its own Flair
and a little bit of a different sound to
it
um but uh I definitely I just love I
love playing with genres I didn't want
each song that's on the same I wanted
something on the album for everybody
yeah you know you were talking just a
second ago about like it being a tough
year last year are you trying to find
your way through and find the direction
and the sound what do you attribute to
being able to actually find that
direction
I'm taking time to live you know taking
a moment to live my life because I was
on tour for so long before covet and
then and it was like constant for like a
year and a half straight I wasn't even
home and then I finally got to slow down
and that's when it hit me like a ton of
bricks I was like okay
here we are I am feeling it so I think
this album really is about what I went
through during covid started off with a
title track diamonds and dance floors I
wrote that that was the first song I
wrote during the pandemic um and it was
about wanting to be on the dance floor
and not in my room
foreign
who would you say is the toughest critic
when it comes to your music like who
listens to it and goes like is it your
niece you can say it's your niece
so like
like parents always have their opinions
they're like very opposite too like my
mom and dad have favorite songs on the
album yeah
so so how is their taste how their
musical tastes differ and when they hear
something they like how do you know
before they open their mouth like how do
you know they like something anytime I'm
singing something that sounds like a
ballad like one of us instantly my dad
cries and my dad's like that that my
dad's like that's that voice oh my God
that's that's my daughter right that's
how he says it and then he starts crying
and I'm like Dad calm down I'm like I
sing all the time what's different about
this song but but like for instance like
one of us is his favor
he's like the softy hey he's the softy
my mom's like I want you to dance I want
you to have upbeat music like and my
dad's like ballads all day
now you recently signed uh to scooter
bronze management company how big is
that for you
it's amazing um
I have nothing
um bad to say about them um but this new
management for sure is
it's amazing I I like I said I just I'm
happy I'm very happy where I'm at right
now this year feels really good and I'm
so blessed to have them on my side they
are incredible managers
you've got such a um
such a cool and eclectic like visual
treatment for everything that you're
putting out there like your video for
example for maybe other problem it's
like a video game and you're skiing how
much input do you have in terms of like
the creative where you want to go with
those things and what you want people to
see
every aspect of every
every creative
converting to
Joseph Khan and I got together and we
made maybe the problem and he's a genius
in himself like he's just incredible he
is he's my Works in such crazy ways for
visuals that I just like like I give him
my idea and he takes the rain for it he
like he just like takes it he's like bye
I'm just gonna make this crazy video
with you chopping this guy's head and he
turns to glitter like seriously laughs
like what's the look when you're out on
the hill legit when you're out there
skiing all right number one are you out
there skiing for real I am not
I am not but I have I have before and
then I've stopped and gone to make a
snow angel and then get some hot
chocolate because I suck at skiing but
one day I will be better there you go
and you know finally we know that you
love to chill just watch some Netflix so
what are you binging right now what's on
your list
White Lotus obviously White Lotus I
finish that it's so funny and good and
just so masterfully created
um and what else
uh a Wednesday of course love Wednesday
she's a brilliant actress
so do you find yourself even if you're
not just thinking about music and
thinking about
you know the visual treatment of things
say you are just watching TV and
watching movies are you pulling those
things into what you do how does that
influence your art
I get extremely inspired by movies and
TV shows like and I love going to a
movie theater and the feeling I get
especially when the end credits come on
and those big you know the big
soundtrack comes on and like you're
watching the end of the movie I mean
that there's nothing like that feeling
you feel like you were in the movie and
you feel so inspired and now so many
visuals come to my mind and so many so
many lyrics and like I want to get in
the studio and start creating
immediately
what type of movie would you want your
song to be at the end of
like an action movie
yeah that you star in
oh my god look that would be great but I
let's like take it slow
no I love I love acting I just I'm the
type of person where if I start acting
I'm really gonna just focus on that for
a few months to a year so whenever I
take a break for music I'll definitely
go all in and acting amazing well we
don't want you to take a break from
music anytime soon so I guess we'll have
to wait for that one yeah right on hey
thank you so much for the time great
chatting with you thank you